Steve so great to have you here thanks
for being a big fan of show happy to be
on it yes big banner she had some big
news in the NFL today we did so what did
you think about that i mean the perhaps
a 1 billion dollar settlement I mean you
can't really put a dollar amount on your
health and the quality of life but the
fact that there is some compensation
being given to those families that is
not just the athletes that its
effectiveness their families it's their
friends and I'm glad to see it because
you know I've been blessed enough to be
in the National Football League for 10
years and seeing what happens to these
players and how their bodies get ravaged
and obviously the most important organ
that you have in your body is your brain
and it controls everything and a dear
friend of mine jr. sale took his life
several years ago and they didn't say it
was because of the injury sustained
while playing 20 years in the National
Football League but I know the guy know
what he was about never would have done
that if he wasn't struggling with some
issues CTE depression anxiety so I'm
glad to see this happen it's a you know
the people that laid the foundation for
what the NFL is today and it's the most
entertaining sport in the world to see
those people be compensated now happy to
see that conversation sounds great but
you really need to prevent these
injuries from taking place in the first
place right I mean what steps do you
think can happen to really help players
protect themselves well that's one of
the reasons I decided to donate my brain
because I want to inspire other players
to do the same because if we're going to
make this game safer to play in there's
going to need some to be some research
being done to be able to figure out what
the genesis is of this problem ALS CTE
memory loss anxiety depression all these
things are affecting these people and
it's happening earlier on then what it
would happen if you weren't a football
player in the National Football League
and so it's a great game it's a very
physical game I don't think you're ever
going to be able to take the physical
contact out of the out of football and
that's what people liked it's
entertaining to see these fantastic
athletes you know tackling each other
and you know the sad reality of it is
you're not going to be able to take
concussions completely out of the game
but Roger Goodell the NF
Commissioner is making the National
Football League a safer place to play
but it's one step at a time and I think
the more research that we can do to
figure out what causes these ailments
later on in life i think that the safer
this game will be four generations to
come suso gadelha is doing something and
that he's in the right direction what
would be your number one message to him
though right now um you know what if it
was your son I think because I'm a
father I've got a son I've got three
daughters and it is a business but at
the same time the commodities are
commodities they're humans and and he
knows that and I think he's putting
great effort forth to be able to make
this game safer but it's a very large
task to undertake so great to have you
on this topic you know and enter moving
forward in this and the potential
settlement of a billion dollars thank
you steve weatherford I gotta take a
look at this ring though we got it in
the house we gotta get a shot of that
late I had to bring it in ladies like it